what what is that that's
one around there
oh yeah that's better hi I'm king of
Michael Key
and today on brain games we're exploring
the brain science of movie Magic
we're gonna face a bunch of really fun
challenges that will show you how your
brain really sees movies ah oh look at
this oh here we go
[Applause]
thanks Jerry oh there you go all right
Jerry please don't eat the cameraman we
talked about this
[Applause]
also
take a look behind the curtain
Ed
to find out how Movie Makers manipulate
our brains
that wasn't you
movies uh the thing about
[Music]
nice it's definitely me okay no it
wasn't oh really okay you're some sort
of expert because you're Tiffany
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
watching crying
[Music]
with the help of movie star Tiffany
haddish we are about to explore some of
the different ways filmmakers trick our
brains while we're watching movies and
why that can be so darn easy to do we're
kicking things off with a quick
experiment as any actor will tell you
the most important element in a movie is
of course
the acting yeah
and now we're going to examine a
performance in a simple scene so
everybody watch your tablets carefully
as we play this clip of Thomas
middleditch and after I'm going to ask
you a question about it and Tiffany can
play as well yes all right okay so roll
the clip
all right now how would you describe
Thomas middleditch in that scene evil
or paternal
it's time to vote evil or paternal
everybody's voted on that side everybody
has voted on this side okay so let's
take a look at the results
all right okay 76.
all right so I'm going to start with
this side this side of the room 76
percent of you said that Thomas looked
paternal correct
Tiffany do you agree hell no
no he looks evil to you hella evil
conniving okay you know what I have a
feeling I know what uh what might be
going on right now because you're not
alone because on this side of the room
let's see the graphic please
oh whoa so 81 of the people on this side
of the room said that Thomas looked easy
yeah because I saw that they saw how he
was looking with the stuff okay all
right okay they know all right so I'm
gonna let everybody in on a little
secret you all saw the exact same shots
of Thomas everybody okay what was
different were the clips you saw right
before his smile so some saw a mom with
a baby while the rest of you saw this
yeah yeah uh that's what you saw that's
what I said that's what you saw that's
what I saw not conniving but can I see
can I think
okay yeah so what's going on here
three words the kulashov effect
who that is that I'm gonna tell you
right now watch this that is the term
for an editing technique that filmmakers
use to manipulate how the viewer
perceives a scene our brains have the
ability to make snap decisions about
other people's behaviors and moods based
on what we observe in their facial
expressions as long as those expressions
are seen in a larger context
Russian filmmaker Lev kulashov believed
that he could change an audience's
interpretation of a character's emotion
if he manipulated the context
editing images can evoke a particular
emotion but this editing sound impact
our brain in the same way
you'd be amazed by how much of what you
hear in a movie is not what it appears
to be
brain games own science correspondent
Cara Santa Maria took a trip to a movie
studio to explore the science of movie
sound
Dan O'Connell is a Foley artist who
creates live sound effects
without realizing it you've heard his
work in Blockbusters Like Pirates of the
Caribbean
Avengers end game
and Jordan Peel's Thriller us the story
of a family terrorized by their evil
doppelgangers
this place is incredible it looks kind
of like a flea market but we're actually
on a movie studio lot it is organized
strangely enough I know it doesn't look
like it
every single object in this room is sort
of a self-made tool to sound like
something else yes nothing you see on
screen is really what it is so we have
to kind of make it up why are our brains
so easily manipulated by sound
we can't help associating sounds with
our own memories because the auditory
cortex is involved in the creation of
those memories every sound we hear comes
with its own emotional triggers based on
our own experiences Foley artists are
skilled at using props to mimic those
sounds which enhances our engagement in
a movie by triggering our own memories
and associations
Dan gives me a chance to do some Foley
working on scenes from us many of the
sounds you hear especially scary ones
travel from the theater speakers to your
brain's amygdala in milliseconds found
as an essential element in establishing
the environment and mood of films it's
pretty good nice job that was awesome
that was great that was great
here I just gave us a glimpse into how
full the artists work behind the scenes
in fact I'm gonna go out on a limb and
I'm gonna bet that even a veteran
actress like our friend Tiffany here
can't identify what's behind certain
sounds this is an experiment we call
fooled by folding
now we're going to play a movie clip
that features a particular sound and see
if you can guess what the Foley artists
actually use to make the sound of
running okay okay all right so here's
the clip
[Music]
okay all right so Tiffany what do you
think they use to make the sound of him
running was it magnetic recording tape
shredded cabbage
cheerleader pom-poms
or actual grass
[Music]
I'ma go with shredded cabbage because I
have run all shredded cabbage before
long story but just know that I know
that's it
Jesus
here's the thing
I 100 believe you so that's good okay
let's see if you're right
[Music]
that looks like cheers and you know what
if I would have thought about it a
little bit harder yeah you know what I'm
saying because I used to run on
cheerleaders pom-poms I'll be like oh
she thinks she better than me
[Laughter]
are you ready for another one she ran
all right what did they use to make the
sound of Wolverine's claws extending
let's go
was it two machetes
a nickel and a horseshoe a dental tool
on an anvil
actual adamantium
well I know it wasn't actual adamant
okay all right you knocked it down to
three because that's hard to come back
but I just remembered I had a flashback
to two machetes I heard before
long story long story not gonna explain
it to machetes too many you're going two
machetes he's going two machetes
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
just suffice it to say she from
Inglewood that's all you need to know oh
you need to know okay so right now
you're working 50 she's one for two
let's see if we get this
one more clip let's go
listen listen carefully okay
okay what's the sound we trying to hear
we trying to hear the burrito we're
talking about the impact the impact the
impact of the burrito impact okay
because it sounds like this one time
when I went camping and the chicken
didn't agree with my stomach okay okay
let's see if that's the choice
what's the choice what made that unique
sound of the burrito
colliding with a beloved Hollywood actor
was it Tiffany what
well that's the first one look at that
was it an ax chopping wood
biting celery
um
a cricket bat hitting a tub of oatmeal
Rebel Wilson actually getting hit with a
burrito
on that one uh uh bite and celery more
crunchy than that now I have heard a
cricket bat go through the air before
never hear oatmeal though I don't think
so it's too much crinkly quickly so I'm
gonna go with d Rebel got hit with the
actual burrito and they put that mic
boom boom right there
ah I see the microphone was right here
came hurting it came hurtling into my
blip what
let's take a look right here player
[Applause]
and it tastes good too
it's one out of three so you got fooled
by Foley yeah but that's okay because
these people are very very talented
we're gonna have more fun with Tiffany
soon
[Applause]
we'll be back in 60 seconds with a
surprise reunion that you will not want
to miss
[Music]
please welcome my former partner from
Mad TV and Key & Peele he is also an
academy award-winning writer and he
directed The critically acclaimed films
get out and us huh yeah
Jordan peeled
[Applause]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
amazing
amazing thank you this is unbelievable
yes now Keegan I I've seen you be a
one-man fully okay I will admit that I
have been known to make some sound
effects in my day but it's not like it's
out of control I don't just do it all
the time it's not just like if you just
started miming something right now that
I would just start doing the soundtrack
[Music]
oh um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean guys come on
[Laughter]
thanks for coming by Buddy ladies and
gentlemen the one and only Jordan Hill
this guy how amazing you're gonna lit
hey oh you know what
um what do you say I uh what do you say
Foley or exit oh no okay all right I'm
sorry I'm sorry I I pushed that was
beyond the pain I'm not comfortable with
that okay I'll see you buddy
all right
see you later buddy
what a good sport ladies and gentlemen
Jordan
we will be right back with more Tiffany
haddish and more movie Magic
[Applause]
[Music]
with some help from Tiffany haddish we
are looking at groovy magic and how it
affects our brains
so far we've seen how the coolershop
effect changes the way we react to a
scene and how fully artists create film
sound
now Mentalist liar sushard is going to
attempt a little movie Magic of his own
Movie Makers construct Illusions to
startle amuse and mystify our minds and
our next guest is famous for doing the
same thing please welcome world-renowned
Master Mentalist leor Sousa
foreign
is known the world over for his skills
as a mentalist
can lior influence Tiffany's choice in
movies movies movies
are all about mind brain manipulations
both of you are going to think of a of a
famous movie we all love movies has to
be a famous movie you don't say it to me
just think about it just think about it
and I'm gonna try somehow
to manipulate you you have a famous
movie I have it I have it I have it look
at me looking at you perfect exactly
what I wanted
and do you have a famous movie
exactly yes exactly what I wanted I like
when you guys in my eyes I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try to influence you okay to
think of that influence you
[Applause]
okay I'm gonna try influence both of you
to think of the exact same movie exact
same movie okay okay I hope this works
okay oh my God it was a glitch in the
system now I have to oh you got them all
flustered okay but only kind of three
okay yes you're gonna shout the name of
the famous movie you were thinking okay
yes one two three black panther
thank you
oh no well mine was romantic it's you
it's you what it's your fault why no
because you did this
no no usually no usually usually she
threw you off she really did throw you
off if this would be a movie yeah the
director would go say cut right you do
100 let's do it again that's it again
but but you know in every good movie
yeah there's a little uh
twist in the plot always always you got
to have that choice
really yeah they should be there should
be some kind of a of a something in the
plot uh well I did I did this is the
striptease part by the way
no because I have come come here come
here I have a little t-shirt here okay
you said Titanic you said black panther
look what I prepare for you
[Applause]
it is a panther with the Titanic in its
mouth
thank you
one more time
[Applause]
how do you do that I don't know I don't
know I have no idea how Leo pulled that
one off but luckily there are a lot of
movie tricks that we can't explain
our eyes are assaulted by multiple
visual images every day how does our
brain help us make sense of this
overwhelming visual clutter our brain
edits Real World Experience like a movie
editor crafts a story by combining the
most meaningful images and filtering out
others that we don't see
try this experiment for yourself
count how many times the hermit crab
bounces off a yellow fish's nose we'll
give you the correct answer when we come
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before the break we asked you how many
times the crab bounced on a yellow
fish's nose
[Music]
the answer is six or at least that's the
story your brain wanted you to see
take a look at what else was going on
when your brain was underwater
did you see the trombone
did you notice when the water in the
tank turned purple
how about when one of the green fish
changed color completely
term for this is event bound
Ary your brain makes decisions as to
what's important in any given situation
or event and edits out conflicting
information just like an editor makes
selections from many different film
elements and combines them into a
continuous story so the next time you
say wow I never saw that maybe your
brain just decided to leave it on The
Cutting Room floor
[Applause]
Tiffany haddish is here helping us
explore how our brain can be fooled by
the tricks filmmakers use in movies
now we're about to get a behind the
scenes look at another bit of big screen
Wizardry
so remember that fun special effects bit
at the top of the show
where my stunt double was kind enough to
do all those backflips for me so I don't
throw out my back
well there's also a super cool high-tech
way to replace an actor in a scene and
that's with the motion capture process
which has been used in movies from The
Lord of the Rings to Avatar to Ted what
we want to test now is whether we can
actually identify a person solely based
on the way they move to do that we put
together four sets of people who are all
closely related in some way Martha and
Samuel our girlfriend and boyfriend
Joey and Ashley are husband and wife
Mariah and Erica are best friends
and Joe and Jasmine her father and
daughter yeah
yay
you like Joe and Jasmine huh I like that
you like dads
so earlier we sent half of these folks
to a studio we're using motion capture
technology they were turned into
animations
in a second we're gonna play video of
them doing a variety of choreographed
movements and you four will see if you
can spot them in a game called your
spouse is a mouse
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you this experiment is based on
something called biological motion
perception which is our brain's ability
to recognize the movements of other
living things even when we have very
little sensory input to work with being
able to quickly detect and classify
other creatures movements as friendly or
threatening was crucial to our ancestors
survival
data on each of our subjects a
sophisticated camera and computer system
was used along with what are called
mocap suits after the computer recorded
the movements of our players we
converted Those computer models into
cartoon characters whose movements match
those of the person wearing the suit
we're going to show you five animated
characters going through a variety of
motions so
agree of difficulty one of the
animations will be an imposter
buddy I want to see the people that were
animated make some moves can you walk as
fast as possible to the marks
all right all right okay stop stop stop
stop stop stop now let me see you Nae
Nae oh
okay can I see you hit the folks on them
put the folks on them bam hit the folks
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay all right okay all right all right
all right I'm ready I'm ready okay you
ready all right I'm like I know that
genetic code thank you so much
please head backstage you guys and we'll
see you in a bit you can head back then
all right
based on what you've seen can you
recognize Sam Joey Erica and Jasmine
all right everybody watch closely
ready
and action
[Applause]
everyone at home it's your turn to Guess
Who's Who and see if you support the
science
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay all right all right okay all right
so what do you guys think were you able
to spot your partners I think so you
think so yeah okay so let's let's find
out if you're right go stand in front of
the door with the animal that you think
was played by your partner you do that
okay
if we got everybody
okay okay
let's find out if you guys are right
Mariah you thought your best friend
Erica was the lizard why
um she walks with her hands close to her
sides and then I think the end where she
was waving it was very like princess
like pageant Queen so I thought it might
be her okay okay Tiff what's your
analysis you know she didn't have a lot
of Rhythm from what I noticed
but that wave was on point that wave
seemed very identifiable okay all right
let's find out
lizard please come out
[Applause]
[Music]
all right best friends best friends okay
we're one for one one for one now Joe
you thought that your daughter Jasmine
was the lion please tell me why well
Jasmine is very athletic and always has
been former cheerleader in fact uh she's
taught me how to floss or attempted to
so I just saw I just saw the floss and
she was the best of the flossers oh it's
a proud dad is up yeah you're being
objective though you're trying to be
absolutely she definitely could have
been in The Flossy Posse
I think that's Jasmine
let's find out lion please come out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a very good that's Daddy's little
girl right there yeah two for two with
two for two everybody
[Applause]
Ashley
you thought your husband Joey was the
cow
why
um it was how he walked and how he moved
his hips when he was dancing but also he
does not know how to floss so the cow
did not he does not know how to floss no
the arms it was it was a lot of this
there was just this yeah and then he
would move his hips and then just do
this again so I saw very identifiable
right yeah I feel like yeah because I
was watching him dance but I had the
little test going and his legs didn't
really come up that much in the dance
moves and his Nae Nae wasn't on on point
right yeah okay let's find out now cow
[Applause]
attaboy Joey get over here White
this is amazing because this is based
solely on motion yeah you guys like your
part your partners walked away and this
is only by watching cartoon animals it's
really fascinating all right we're three
for three no pressure Martha so here's
the deal
we had the Imposter in here
so your boyfriend is either behind the
pig or the zebra we don't know yet we
don't know but you're going zebra okay
he's gonna kill me for saying this but I
looked for the animal with the least
amount of Rhythm
and that's how I knew
now that's a toss-up because Joey's
right here
[Applause]
what's your analysis now I'm gonna tell
you right now the pig had moves the pig
looked like it was classically trained
in ballet okay and then I was watching
the zebra and I said that zebra that
zebra play video games
no I'm with you girl so let's find out
zebra please come out
foreign
you guys were four for four
you never fell for the Imposter Pig
great job everybody that's great that's
amazing
and guess what science tells us that
human beings will generally recognize
their loved ones movements even when
they're projected onto a giant
anthropomorphic cow and there they are
right there look at these guys watch us
yeah
yeah
that's great ready movie fans here is
another way to test your powers of
perception I'm going to show you a
series of faces as they go by keep track
of how many different people you see
[Music]
we'll have the answer when we come back
[Music]
before the break we asked you how many
people you saw in this sequence of
photos
so how many people did you spot audience
two
I'm getting a lot of chews and some
threes
you probably recognize actress Chris
Evans and Chris Hemsworth
but what you missed were the photos of
their stunt doubles
the correct answer is actually Four
I know they're they're total doppelgang
which is insane
[Music]
Hollywood is able to get away with stunt
doubles thanks to something called a
continuity field which is our brain's
tendency to see a face as the same from
one moment to the next even when it's
not the same that tendency is actually a
survival mechanism that gives us a sense
of stability in an otherwise visually
confusing world if we didn't have it
every time we saw a friend from a
different angle we'd perceive them as a
stranger awkward
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
here's what I was thinking we are
shooting in Los Angeles here in
Hollywood everybody wants to be director
producer actor actresses so I want to
give the chance for someone in the
audience and you and me and everyone
together to create
an imaginary movie a movie that never
existed okay and will probably never be
existed but let's so who wants to help
me who wants to be director let's get
some people
uh you come over here both of you come
come come come you will stand here I'm
gonna tell you what's going to happen
from this side all right I need a good
director's Minds a good you're gonna be
here and right above you're gonna be
here come over here come and stand give
the medical Applause
from here
take the microphone we need the
microphone for them as well so this is
what's gonna be we are going to create
an imaginary movie okay in a movie as
producers you're going to be the
producers and the directors okay we're
just gonna look from the side uh you
need uh let's do this you need the a
genre okay you need a genre for the
movie we have lots of lots of those uh
you also need um like the main uh actor
yep and you need like let's do the main
actress also okay okay so I'm Gonna Let
You freely do you know each other by the
way no perfect there's lots of fights in
the movie industry
lots of fights I want you to really have
a debate and come to a conclusion think
of a actor actress start the start going
and let's see what happened ghost who
should be the lead actor who should be
lead actress uh Zac Efron
I I do like Zac Efron yeah Dwayne
Johnson he's too big yeah we need like
medium
maybe Jamie Foxx
I need a decision Jamie Foxx or Will
Smith Jamie Foxx yes
okay okay okay uh actress please go
actress go uh Mila Kunis Emma Watson
Emma Watson cardi B cardi B cardi B so
cardi B going once gonna be going twice
she doesn't like it she doesn't like it
she's saying
never mind girl should we just go back
to Emma Watson because she's like if
we're gonna keep it PG we can do Emma so
we got a movie
sci-fi
robots robots
[Music]
yeah I like horror horror movie with
Jamie Foxx and Emma Watson yes yes yes
this is a National Geographic so we have
to have an animal name and animal
penguin what penguin penguin
you know
name a color
lavender
now I'm going to explain something to
you I I try to influence you a little
bit Lavender is not an ordinary color no
it's not an ordinary it's this yeah okay
can you join them for a second
um Tiffany come with me for a second
drum roll everybody
nobody could know Jamie Foxx Emma Watson
horror movie
penguin and you said lavender lavender
yeah ladies and gentlemen you ready one
two three I give you
the lavender penguins
starting Jamie Fox Emma Watson
okay
the Knights of the lavender penguins
come on man all right before we go any
further our legal department wants us to
stress that this is not a real movie
which is really too bad because I think
that a movie with a title of Night of
the lavender Penguins I smell an Oscar I
smell an Oscar I leore
you are truly gifted and confounding I
don't know what's happening
[Applause]
another way filmmakers can evoke emotion
is by using a production technique
called the dolly Zoom Alfred Hitchcock
was famous for using methods like this
to alter the viewer's experience
camera lens Zooms in on a focal point in
this case the door while the camera
moves backwards on a track known as a
dolly the dolly Zoom was used by
Hitchcock in his 1958 film vertigo to
illustrate the terror and disorientation
experience by Jimmy Stewart's character
and similar techniques used by other
filmmakers like Spike Lee and Steven
Spielberg
haven't gone in the ocean since
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
how are you feeling in that thing I'm
feeling like I'm on a bad date
well I got to tell the shoulder straps
are good look for you oh thank you yes
all right uh Tiffany it's the part of
the show we've all been waiting for or
in your case possibly dreading a high
octane mental obstacle course we invite
all of our guests to attempt this is the
gauntlet
each week our celebrity guests play the
same series of games designed to test
their balance perception and focus
can Tiffany haddish Master our mental
maze
it all starts with balance okay are you
ready now because when I say go you're
gonna pour water from this pitcher into
this glass you're gonna have 15 seconds
please put
Tiffany in place oh I see how you do me
uh when we say go you're gonna start
pouring this way
I can't wait to do this to Meryl Streep
go
[Music]
[Applause]
and John John there we go all right
there we go station two here we go
watch the video but tell me what you
hear okay okay
A Buck in a box
a duck in a box
a duck in a box that is incorrect that
is it correct what do you mean look at
it but tell me what you hear okay second
video
bill is a baker
Hill is a vaker
oh that's uh that's that's close but not
correct next one next one
that's my bat suit
that's my battle
that's correct that is correct that's my
bad suit
all right next up
decision three is intuition it's you
against lior in three games of rock
paper scissors you have to win one game
you just got to beat him one time okay
one second before we start thank you to
do this
[Applause]
you guys ready okay okay round one go
one two three
round two go one two three all right
round three okay here we go
one two three okay here we go
oh
she was very good it's okay
[Applause]
why do I feel like this is a rig game
now we're gonna do mental processing
okay okay
you need to match the color of the
letters on the ball with the name of the
color on the bin okay okay there you go
you ready you're gonna have 30 seconds
you got to run back and forth too you
got to come over here baby
all right I'm gonna give you this at
some point you're gonna hear this
and that means the names are gonna
change on the bins okay okay all right
all right
so I'm gonna give you this ball in 30
seconds start when you take it from me
[Laughter]
spend more time with you too honey so
it's fine with me
hello okay
[Applause]
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going
two one
oh all right okay all right
not bad that was good that was good
your final challenge this is maintaining
composure okay all you need to do is
hold on to this tray and balance these
glasses okay and then just okay hold the
tray
now very slowly just take a deep breath
look at the camera
look at the camera don't don't drop it
you're gonna stay there just relax don't
touch me just maintain I'm not gonna
touch you maintain your composure
[Applause]
away from me right now get your dead ass
away from me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know
[Applause]
and a girl too
sorry Jerry did you even get a Jerry oh
my gosh
laughs
[Applause]
so Tiff how was this experience for you
let's just be honest you had Kevin up
there we never can't understand what
he's saying anyway
A Buck in a box
a duck in the Box that is incorrect
then you played rock paper scissors
against leor
no it's really uh unfair Advantage
because he read your mind but he needed
to teach me how to read minds and then
let's play again
you looked fantastic doing it it's
designed to kind of rattle you and you
did and you did very well you did very
well
thanks for watching see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]